former First Lady Michelle Obama is
discussing the hurtful and racist
stereotypes that she confronted during
her time in the White House and when she
was on the campaign trail the
best-selling author best-selling author
all right this book is selling close to
12 million copies sat down with me for
an exclusive wide-ranging interview at
the essence festival in New Orleans on
Saturday night now the expose it was his
25th anniversary celebrates black music
and culture mrs. Obama talked about how
both Republicans and Democrats targeted
her for being a powerful black woman the
experience that she also chronicles in
her popular memoir becoming I know there
are a lot of young kids out there who
see me and Barack now write they see us
as the former first they see us when we
were walking out of the White House but
they don't remember how much how many
punches we took to get there so now I'm
Michelle Obama and beloved but for a
minute there I was an angry black woman
who was emasculating her husband who was
somebody to be feared because that was
part of the political game was that as I
got more popular and started being more
of an asset to my husband it was
interesting that that's when people of
all sides and I stopped to say people
from all sides Democrats and Republicans
tried to take me out by the needs but
the reason I share that story is because
I want people to especially young people
to know that we all go through those
moments where people try to define us
before we have an opportunity to find
ourselves so instead of letting it
defeat me I had a very clear vision of
what I had to do when I went into the
White House as first lady I knew that it
was up to me that I wouldn't get the
benefit of the doubt I wouldn't get the
the benefit of being treated as the
Britta's honored first lady as I wrote I
would have to earn my grace yeah she
says she said a lot of very powerful
things we had talked at one point about
being underestimated and over-delivering
she said but at some point you get tired
of being underestimated yes and we
talked about being an empty-nester Sasha
Malia were seven and ten when they moved
in now they're 18 and 21 they're gonna
be empty nesters Barack and Michelle
Obama life is good you can watch more of
my interview with Michelle Obama at CBS
news.com we'll be right back